you know there are some who would argue
that it's not the smartest long-term
career strategy to aggressively
antagonize and purposefully make an
enemy out of one of the wealthiest the
most powerful corporations in the world
and um it's even more reckless you might
say when this corporation
happens to control 90
of the book sales in the country and you
make part of your living by selling
books
and you might be right about all of that
but um all i can say is that still it's
totally worth it there have been
a number of big developments since we
talked yesterday about the leaked videos
uh over at amazon of an amazon meeting
where the employees complained and
whined and at one point actually cried
over my children's book as much as i'd
love to play those clips again um i'm
not gonna do that but you can always go
watch them if you want and they're
they're crying about my children's book
johnny the walrus of course which is
available for sale
over at amazon uh you go to
johnnywalrus.com
they call the book triggering traumatic
uh problematic
harmful they were also incensed that the
book was originally categorized as an
lgbt children's book and even more in
sense that i was as they claimed
bragging about it publicly and trolling
them they claimed
now i personally take great exception to
any accusation
that i have bragged or trolled that is
simply
not the kind of thing that i would do
does that sound like me come on
but that's how they interpreted it and
they were very upset
now after the show yesterday some more
developments amazon
sent an email to our publishing division
dw books and they informed us that our
ads for johnny the walrus have been
banned from the platform
they said that we were conducting that
they rather were conducting a quote
unquote periodic review
which just so happens to coincide
directly with these embarrassing videos
coming out
and me making fun of them for it so just
like at the same time coincidentally
there's this totally random and periodic
review that they conducted and they and
they discovered that oh we actually
can't run ads for the book anymore
because it's not appropriate
the ads are inappropriate here's what
the email actually says this is what it
says exactly
your ad is not appropriate for all
audiences
i mean despite the fact that it's
literally a board book for preschoolers
but anyway to ensure a good customer
experience we reserve the right to
restrict ads that contain elements that
may not be appropriate for all audiences
this may include erotica
content on sexual preferences such as
bdsm
incestuous relationships sexual contact
with persons under the age of 18
self-help content such as dating get
rich quick or weight loss books or
content that promotes endorses or
incites potentially dangerous or harmful
activity
i have to say credit words do
i do appreciate how they have put
self-help books on the same tier as bdsm
and incest self-help books are
just as disgraceful and gross as that
they're saying and and i don't disagree
necessarily
but which category does johnny the
walrus fall into
like what do you think johnny the walrus
is if that's how you're interpreting it
whatever amazon thinks i can assure any
potential buyer of this book
there is no bdsm in johnny the walrus
there is no incest there is no sexual
content of any kind at all actually
it also doesn't promote dangerous
activities it promotes the opposite
so what is is it a self-help book is
that what they're saying
is it self-help for walruses
is that the claim i don't know
the answer of course is that the book is
none of these things and they know that
it's none of these things the book and
the ad are 100 appropriate for all ages
even by the standards of amazon's own
policies
removing it out of out of revenge it's
an act of revenge quite explicitly and
obviously
and if it wasn't already explicit enough
they also declassified the book from the
children's category
so it's no longer listed on amazon as a
children's book
amazon has put it into the political
commentary section of the site now
ironically them placing it in the
political commentary section is itself
political commentary on their part it's
editorialization
about the book they don't like the book
they don't personally think people
should read it to their kids so they're
not going to list it as a children's
book
even though it unequivocally is just
that
like this is not what booksellers are
supposed to do
uh if you're gonna carry the book
and it's a children's book then then any
more than if someone wrote a sci-fi book
and you didn't personally think it was
great sci-fi so you're like i'm not
going to put it in that section i'm
going to put in this section over here
but you might not like it but that is
without a doubt the genre of the book
um in fact my book is significantly more
age-appropriate than many other
children's books on the sites which are
allowed to be advertised as well but
amazon wasn't done
next and again this all happened
yesterday
um next amazon turned its sites on my
other book what is a woman which will be
released in june and is also available
for sale on amazon you go to www.com um
they conducted another conveniently
timed periodic review so these are two
periodic reviews that they happened to
conduct yesterday while this was
happening and they sent another email to
dw books announcing that our ad campaign
for that book has been banned as well
their reasoning was slightly more
specific they say your ad contains
content that appears to infer or claim
to diagnose treat reverse or question
gender identity or sexual orientation
now of course
they haven't read the book so they
couldn't possibly know if it contains
those kinds of
things all the book all the book cover
does is ask a question what is a woman
they appear to be admitting i guess that
the simple question what is a woman
that question itself may have the effect
of
reversing gender identity
like just asking the question what is a
woman
the question itself invalidates gender
identity
which appears to be what they're saying
and in fact they're right about that if
that is what they're saying
but um
what does that say about gender identity
in that case
as for the content of the actual book it
actually contains mostly my
conversations with other people
including several supposed experts quote
unquote on that side of the conversation
i mean it's a book with um interviews
with
a gender affirming therapist and
gender affirming pediatricians
and gender affirming surgeons to use
their euphemisms for all those things
but you know the difference is that i
don't blindly accept everything these
experts say i ask them
questions skeptical questions
as questions you know questions are
supposed to be skeptical by their nature
and apparently that's not allowed
now we're not taking any of this lying
down though um amazon didn't like how
johnny the walrus was originally
classified on their site
so we decided
if you didn't like that then you're
really not gonna like this amazon we
decided to classify my what is a woman
book
as a biology text
after all contagi brown jackson said
that you know only a biologist is
qualified to speak about the subject it
is a it's a biological
subject and so it made sense that our
book is it's it's there for a biology
book it's a biology textbook
and um so that's how we listed it and
right now as you can see what is a woman
is the best-selling biology book on
amazon as it currently stands um i'm
sure the employees absolutely love that
and they can take it out of that
category which i'm sure they're gonna do
but it will forever and always have the
distinction as a best-selling biology
book we got it in there we got the
screenshot there it is
i may and and this means that for the
rest of my life and you know that i'll
make good on this
this is a a credential that i'm going to
bring with me
i can now start any argument i have
with someone anytime i have to make a
point i can say well
as the best-selling author of a or
rather as the author of a best-selling
biology book
dot dot dot
meanwhile johnny the walrus itself in
spite of the efforts to suppress it by
amazon became and is still the number
one book overall across the entire
platform it is number one on the best
seller list overall
and um given that as mentioned amazon
controls nearly all of the book sales in
america we can say without a doubt that
johnny the walrus is right now the
best-selling book period in the entire
country out of all the books being sold
out of the thousands of books it is
number one
and we achieved this even though no
brick and mortar stores would go
anywhere near this book
and even though amazon doesn't want it
and is doing everything it can to censor
it and suppress it is still the number
one book in america now
this is all extremely
funny and i tend to focus a lot
on the humor of it because that's the
most fun thing to talk about
uh but
we would be missing i think a big part
of the point if we concentrated solely
on the humor of it
the fact is that
the number one book in the country
is a pre-school board book
satirizing left-wing gender ideology
now that would have been unthinkable up
until
well right now when it actually happened
and i think this is just another line of
evidence
that the cultural tide is beginning to
turn that's not to say that the battle
is won by any means as i am constantly
reminding everyone and myself if there's
going to be a victory in this in this
war
that victory will be generations down
the line you and i
will live and die in a culture that is
fundamentally hostile to us
that's the reality so you might as well
strap in and learn to enjoy the fight
that's the record that's the advice i
give everyone when they tell well how
are we going to win what do we
just learn learn to enjoy fighting
because that's all you're going to have
it's it's that's it
you're not living in uh in peace time
and you never will be living in those
times maybe your grandchildren will
though if you fight hard enough
and that's that's enough for me i could
take solace in that
and though victory is far down the line
that doesn't mean we can
uh that we're not able to to make
progress towards that end which i think
we are right now
johnny the walrus is even i will admit
a very very small
salvo in the war but even so
a win is a win
nothing wrong with enjoying them when
they come well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content